oh hello I didn't see you there
I did I lied hi YouTube my good friend
and pal asexual companion so as you've
noticed I've been using this gray CH in
a box channel as more of a talking at
you to you however you see it Channel so
here's what happened to me today I went
on a couple auditions today which is why
I my hair looks like this I don't do
this to my hair if I don't have a reason
to I own hair stuff so I went on this
audition today and it was kind of like a
last minute on this show so I'm waiting
in the waiting room when this guy walks
in with his son presumably though the
guy looked older so I thought maybe he
was like a mani or something and this
was the boy that he was babysitting but
then I soon realized after he called him
his son that it was his son and the
voice name was Jack and oops I'm here if
there was a box of white trash Crayola
Crayons that were really classy this is
so anyway he's there with his son Jack
and Jack is a very outspoken boy he's
you know kind of bopping around like all
kids do he's very verbal auditory you
quacks out of his mouth a lot I thought
it was very charming and sweet and cute
but his dad was getting so mad at him he
was like check sit down Jack sit down
Jack was just trying to tell me about
the chocolate and peanut butter
combination of granola bars that he was
eating so wasn't a big deal I wasn't
offended by it but his dad was like
getting so furious he kept saying Jack
were in my office right now so I need
you to calm down and sit down and I felt
really bad but the kid being a child it
was all like totally bouncing off of him
he did not feel threatened by his dad he
did not heed any of his words and then
he did the thing that I think is so
funny he finally reached his limit with
Jack and he got right in his face and he
said Jack if you don't calm down I'm
gonna call the police
at first I was like oh my god he's awful
but then I remembered I was how you say
a problem child I was younger the way
Paris Hilton can throw a party I would
throw a temper tantrum just like that I
remember one time I'm mom my dad got
divorced I was younger so my mom was a
single mom for a while and she's since
been remarried so don't feel like she's
by yourself and I was throwing a temper
tantrum in the grocery store and
apparently I grabbed my mom's hair and I
ripped it out of her head a chunk of it
the only thing I remember after that was
that she drove me to the police station
she drove the station wagon with the
fake wood finally to the police station
bounce in the backseat she told me to
look at that police station because if I
was bad I was gonna end up there and
there was a little girl walking in the
police station with an adult I don't
know why or she was visiting someone or
something and my mom pointed to that
girl and she said you see that girl
she's been a bad girl and they're taking
her into the police station and I
remember being petrified after that and
thinking that I was gonna go to jail if
I was bad
and so hearing that today out of that
man's mouth just let me think oh that's
just a common tactic I do not understand
parenting no wonder there's so many they
had parents in the law and my mom was
very great and it still is a very great
parent so I don't blame her at all but I
guess you just get to a point where the
only thing you can do is tell them that
they're going to jail so that's what
happened to me today I don't think I got
the audition but it was a great time see
you guys later
thanks for listening YouTube